c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir ce rapport de human rights
watch sur le mali il dénonce les
exactions commises par les femmes à les
forces armées armée malienne et par des
djihadistes sur les populations human
rights watch demande aux autorités de
transition de faciliter le déroulement
des enquêtes indépendantes
nous étions en direct tout à l'heure
avec bénédicte jeannerod directrice
france de human rights watch
la poursuite du dialogue entre partis
politiques et les autorités en guinée ce
mardi c'est le parti du président déchu
alpha condé est la principale coalition
de l'opposition qui ont été reçus par
les autorités de transition
nous serons à conakry dans ce journal et
à la fin de cette édition nous irons au
kenya le pays n'échappe pas à la
sécheresse qui frappe l'afrique de l'est
nos correspondants dans le pays se sont
rendus dans un village d'une région très
touchée reportage à suivre
on commence donc par ce rapport de human
rights watch qui dénonce des exactions
commises par l'armée malienne mais pas
seulement le rapport épingle également
les attaques djihadistes à répétition
qui cible à la fois les femmes à et les
populations bénédicte jeannerod
directrice france de l'eau angie était
avec nous tout à l'heure elle est
revenue sur le contenu de ce rapport
écoutez
nous avons mené des entretiens avec des
dizaines de témoins et d'autres
personnes et nous avons documenté huit
incidents dans le centre et dans le sud
ouest du mali qui implique les groupes
armés islamistes et l'armée malienne et
ses différents événements que nous avons
documenté se sont soldées par le meurtre
de 107 personnes des civils y compris
des suspects et donc par milieu des
commerçants des chefs de village des
chefs religieux et des enfants et la
plupart des victimes ont présumément
était sommairement exécutés alors pour
ce qui est des groupes armés islamistes
ils sont impliqués dans 36 meurtre sur
les 107 depuis le mois de décembre et
elles ont notamment tué je signale cette
cet incident là que nous avons documenté
tué 32 personnes dont au moins six
enfants lors d'une embuscade qui a été
tendue à des commerçants qui circulez en
bus début décembre alors qu'il se
rendait dans un marché à bandiagara et
beaucoup de ces personnes ont été brûlés
vifs un des témoins qui nous avons
interviewé parle d'un véritable d'un
véritable carnage et du côté des de
l'armée donc qui est impliqué dans 71
meurtres la plupart lors d'opérations
antiterroristes et elle s'est livrée à
des attaques manifestement en
représailles à des morts à des morts
après la mort de deux soldats et elle a
tué de nombreuses personnes dans des
villages mais aussi début mars au moins
trente cinq suspects qui étaient détenus
dans le camp militaire de dia ben ali et
dont les suspects tués dans les corps
ont été dans les corps calcinés ont été
retrouvés à proximité à une dizaine de
kilomètres de diéval il s'agit là de la
de la pire allégations contre l'armée
que nous avons documenté depuis depuis
2012 alors dans votre rapport vous
parlez également d'hommes blancs qui ne
parle pas français qui seraient aussi
responsables d'exactions
alors effectivement dans certains
témoins qui nous avons que nous avons
interviewés ont décrit la présence de
soldats blancs qu'il ne parlait pas
qu'ils parlaient une langue en fait
qu'il ne comprenait pas dans plusieurs
opérations de l'armée et des opérations
au cours desquelles des exactions ont
été ont été commises notamment
d'ailleurs celle que j'évoquais juste
avant qui a concerné l'exécution
sommaire de trente cinq suspects détenus
au camp de diabaly donc donc début mars
et par suppositions en fait comme barkan
et à kouba et ni la minus ma ne sont
opérationnels dans cette zone on peut
penser qu'il s'agisse de rue sont
engagés auprès du groupe auprès du
groupe wagner donc je mènerai de soi je
ne prends pas position sur l'utilisation
de troupes comme comme wagner mais en
revanche on surveille une documentons de
manière très approfondie leurs
comportements et c'est ce que nous
allons continuer à faire et ça fera
probablement l'objet d'un prochain
rapport de la part des human rights
watch dans la prochainement dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines alors aujourd'hui vous demander
aux autorités de transition de faciliter
la conduite des enquêtes indépendantes
oui alors en fait comme toujours ce que
nous documentons ça produit des
allégations qui finalement ne sont que
des allégations qui demande à être
investigués et c'est pour ça que nous
demandons au gouvernement de mener lui
mène des enquêtes crédibles sur les
différents incidents et les différentes
allégations qui sont documentés dans
notre dans notre rapport est également
de favoriser ou de faciliter des
enquêtes indépendantes qui sont menées
par la section droits de l'homme de la
minus m'a également par la commission
nationale des droits de l'homme c'est
très important qu'elle qu'elle le fasse
on se on salue d'ailleurs le fait que le
gouvernement ait annoncé déjà
l'ouverture d' enquête sur trois des
incidents que nous documentons dans
notre dans notre rapport et je dirais
que là que la question des enquêtes
c'est non seulement une question
essentielle pour rendre justice aux
victimes et à leurs familles et puis
aussi pour sanctionner les personnes qui
qui subissent qui par donkey perpète qui
perpètrent 1 qui commettent de tels de
telles exactions mais c'est aussi une
question je dirais de
de crédibilité vis-à-vis des populations
on sait que la défiance de la part d'un
certain nombre de communautés à l'égard
des autorités est un terreau ou un
terrain très favorable pour le
recrutement des groupes armés
djihadistes donc le fait que les
autorités mènent des enquêtes sérieuses
traîne des mesures ou des sanctions
contre les personnes qui se prête à de
telles exactions c'est aussi une
question de rétablir la confiance et de
crédibilité vis-à-vis de deux
communautés qui ont un grand sentiment
de défiance
en in et les consultations entre
l'opposition et le pouvoir de transition
se poursuivent ce mardi c'était au tour
du rpg la formation de l'ex président
alpha condé de la principale coalition
d'opposition de rencontrer l'exécutif la
correspondance à conakry de malik a
quittés c'est à huis clos que les
échanges se déroulent au au ministère de
la demande illustration devant lequel je
me trouve ce mardi 5 coalition étaient
présentes dont le rpg arc en ciel le
parti du président dessus alpha condé et
l'alliance nationale pour l'alternance
démocratique une coalition dirigé par
l'opposant cellou dalein diallo ses
représentants sont reçus par le ministre
de l'administration et son équipe au nom
du gouvernement que veulent les partis
politiques qui ont exigé ces
concertations il espère à discuter
directement avec la junte au pouvoir
pour déterminer les termes de la
transition à commencer par sa durée qui
n'est toujours pas connue à la fin des
échanges les leaders sont apparus plutôt
confiant nous avons senti une ouverture
d'esprit de leur part et nous avons
aussi exclu mais les mêmes opinions nous
pensons que effectivement c'est une
bonne chose que la classe politique est
que tous les acteurs de la société
puissent se retrouver avec le cnrd pour
qu'ensemble on conjugue le même veine
l'aspect qui retient notre attention
c'est comment aller aux élections
comment tenir le fichier et lettrage
nous tous souhait c'est de nous
donner une échéance
une méfiance convenable consommables
pour qu'on aille aux élections d'après
le ministre de l'administration les
acteurs de la société civile les ombres
religion ou encore la presse font partie
de ces groupes invités à ce dialogue
dans la cité l'actualité en bref et en
images cette énième retard dans le
processus électoral qui doit mener à la
désignation d'un nouveau président en
somalie le pays n'a pas achevé les
élections à la chambre basse du
parlement à la date butoir fixée ce
mardi le gouvernement somalien avait
déjà repoussé le mois dernier au 15 mars
le délai pour boucler la désignation des
membres de cette chambre basse l'hommage
à l'écrivain mouloud feraoun l'ambassade
l'ambassadeur de france en algérie
accompagné du ministre algérien des
anciens combattants à déposer ce mardi
au nom du président emmanuel macron une
gerbe de fleurs en l'honneur de
l'écrivain algérien assassiné il y à 60
ans parle aux as une organisation
clandestine opposés à l'indépendance de
l'algérie une gerbe de fleurs déposée
devant une plaque à la mémoire de
mouloud feraoun a posé à l'endroit où il
a été assassiné sur les hauteurs d'alger
au sénégal un médiateur dans la crise en
casamance a appelé à l'arrêt de
l'opération en cours de l'armée
sénégalaise contre des rebelles
indépendantistes dans cette région du
sud du pays l'armée sénégalaise avait
annoncé avoir lancé dimanche une
offensive contre des rebelles de
casamance pour démanteler les bases de
leurs chefs militaires
et on vous parle de nouveau de la
sécheresse en afrique de l'est elle
continue à faire des dégâts cette
semaine nous vous emmenons dans le nord
du kenya nos correspondants se sont
rendus dans le comté éditio l'eau où il
n'y a pas eu de saison de pluie depuis
deux ans caroline qui me et bastien
renouil se sont rendus dans le village
de ghulam away ce qui signifie en
swahili manger des pierres un an
particulièrement évocateur reportage
soixante dix mille animaux d'élevage
sont morts dans le comté 10 yolo au
cours des six derniers mois faute de
nourriture et d'eau cet homme essaie de
faire survivre sans chèvres et 50
moutons
saynètes avant depuis notre village de
coup là-bas ou et nous devions seulement
marcher deux heures pour trouver des
pâturages
maintenant il faut marcher environ cinq
heures la faute à niasse du coin dakota
vous times
beaucoup ont perdu leur troupeau cent
vingt mille personnes ont besoin d'aidé
alimentaire dans ce comté ce fourrage
permet d'avoir un peu d'eau mais il est
insuffisant pour abreuver toute une
région
nous avons tellement de problèmes ici
nous partageons l'eau avec nos bêtes
mais elles sont si nombreuses à cause de
la sécheresse les gens viennent de toute
la région dans notre village
ils viennent d'endroits très lointain
les animaux sont prioritaires et
arrivent chaque jour par milliers
impossible pour sept fermiers de se
résoudre à les laisser mourir mieux vaut
privé les hommes de
notre principale source de revenu c'est
le bétail ont le vent et ensuite on peut
acheter de la nourriture à nos enfants
quand on le vend et on peut payer
l'école je n'allais pas comme fès le
gouvernement a déployé une aide
d'urgence mais pour le responsable de la
lutte contre la sécheresse il faut
désormais développer des solutions sur
le long terme y changer les modes de vie
here we go to be si nous parvenons à
créer de la résilience au sein des
communautés elles ne souffriront plus de
ces problèmes mais il y aura des
sécheresses et des inondations et encore
d'autres problèmes mais les gens seront
capables de facilement faire face à ces
risques ont convoqué blick il compte
notamment développer l'irrigation pour
permettre les cultures une révolution
pour ces communautés pastorales mais les
autorités considèrent qu'il faudra en
passer par là pour s'adapter au
changement climatique et aux sécheresses
de plus en plus fréquentes
cette bonne nouvelle pour finir
l'architecte burkinabè francis kéré
pionnier des constructions durables au
service des populations s'est vu
décerner le prix pris de care il est le
premier africain à recevoir la plus
haute distinction de la profession il
est notamment connu pour son implication
dans des projets de vie quotidienne
comme des écoles et de nom et une de
nombreux pardon et nombreux de ces
ouvrages sont situés sur le continent
africain notamment au burkina faso au
bénin au togo au mali ou au kenya
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena et merci à vous de nous être
fidèles restés avec nos plats faut
considérer sur france 24
[Musique]